every four years  each american voter has the privilege  and patriotic duty to decide  who is the lesser evil it's the question  that's been at the heart of our great  democracy for decades  that's why political scientists  developed a machine to assist with that  process  the evil meter intakes data on revolving  door politics  influence peddling insider trading and a  host of other parameters  so that every american voter has a clear  and obvious  [Music]  can we get evil meters that go to 11  those do go to 11.  hey what is going on someone get the  likes  oh come on you're fighting over this  again  isn't there a better way like what i  don't know it just seems like we're so  focused on the lesser part that we're  missing something  oh yeah who the [ __ ] needs that machine  unity 20 20. let's try this without the  evil  you